this morning investigators are still
trying to figure out what caused that
fire at the mount charleston lodge yeah
you saw that right here is breaking news
friday morning as firefighters were
battling those flames hector mejia
joining us now live in the newsroom
hector i know a lot of brides are
scrambling for places to go but really
for many of us we're just trying to
remember that beautiful spot yeah
heather and those brides having to make
last-minute plans meanwhile right now
we've learned it could take several more
days or even weeks for investigators to
announce what started the fire and many
we talked with say it's still hard to
believe a piece of las vegas history is
gone and take a look our aviator drone
captured video from the air showing the
aftermath those are the large flames
that gutted the mount charleston lodge
leaving only a shell of a building
investigators think it started near the
dining room area but they do not believe
anyone was there at the time the place
was closed as of this morning no word
yet about what started the fire to begin
with many are remembering this place for
the decades of good memories
gathering place
you know not just for
visitors coming up but it was a
gathering place for
you know our community the residents up
here all the folks that work up here
through the forest service
lodge says it plans to rebuild and
recreate the charm so many locals loved
and heather and john
the good news in all of this is that no
one was hurt firefighters responded from
all around the valley multiple
jurisdictions and they managed to keep
the fire from spreading to the nearby
trees and cabins in our newsroom hector
mejia live local now